قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي الرئيس
بايدن ابلغ قاده مجموعه السبع موافقاته
على تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه على طائرات
اف 16 واضاف في مؤتمر صحفي عقده على هامش
قمه السبع باليابان ان تدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه على الطائرات يتطلب عده اشهر
وسيتم اتخاذ قرار خلال الاشهر القادمه
بشان الدول التي ستزود اوكرانيا
بالمقاتلات
ابلغ الرئيس بايدن قاده مجموعه السبع
موافقاته على مسعا مشترك لتدريب اوكرانيين
على مقاتلات الجيل الرابع التي تشمل
الشهور القليله الماضيه
ركزنا نحن حلفاؤنا على منح اوكرانيا
منظومات تسالح وتدريب تحتاجها لشن هجومي
الربيع والصيف وبينما يمضي تدريب الطيران
الاوكرانيين في طريقه سنعمل مع حلفائنا
لنقرر اجل تسليم الطائرات الحربيه
واعدادها ومن يسلمها